وكان لدوله الرئيس الوزراء والوفد المرافق
له
مباحثات مهمه
مع السيد المستشار الالماني
وتواصلنا الى تفاهمات كبيره حول التعاون
المشترك
في مختلف المجالات
وخاصه في قطاع الطاقه
والكهرباء والعلاقات الاقتصاديه
كما كان لنا حضور قوي
في شباط في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
وتم اجراء العديد من اللقاءات والمباحثات
هناك
اود في هذه المناسبه ان نسجل كلمه شكر
للسيده الوزيره
ولحكومه المانيا الاتحاديه
على دعم المستمر
للشعب الالماني الدعم المستمر للشعب
العراقي
وبجميع مكوناته
في حربه ضد عصابات والرهابي 11
لقد لعبت سلاح الالماني ميلان
دورا مهما
في كسر شوكه الهجمات
وخاصه الهجمات بواسطه دبابات من قبل
العصابات داعش
وكان انتصارا للعراقيين
وانتصارا للشعبين وانتصارا لجميع الشعوب
اللي شاركت في هذه المعارك وفي دحر
عصابات داعش ودوله داعش
كما اود ان اشكر على الحكومه الالمانيه
على مساعدتها
السخيه لاعاده اعمار المدن
التي تعرضت للدمار
بسبب الحرب
على داعش وخاصه مدينه موصل ومحافظه
نينوى بصوره عامه
ونسجل الشكر للبرلمان الاتحادي في برلين
على الموقف المشرف
باعترافه بالظلم الذي لحق بالمكون
ه بان الانتهاكات التي تعرضت